federico et dans une dernière hausse
perd en deux blocs moi je suis tout
depuis ce temps il ya maintenant un
désir à la fois lorsque ces noix spécial
la procédure fait en sorte qu'un taux
élevé de siéger durant des temps
déterminé est ce que c'est vraiment
nécessaire de passer toute une nuit à
débattre pour quelque chose dont on
connaît déjà l'issue c'est un peu
archaïque de siéger la nuit pour
l'adoption de grandpré le faire de jo et
on arriverait au même résultat
plus les députés qui sont là depuis le
début de soirée lentement mais sûrement
nous en sommes à à l'étude détaillée du
projet de loi 127 loi spéciale écrit sur
le coin de la table
un soir du 27 février au niveau de la
conciliation travail famille parce qu'on
est dû pour une réforme du règlement de
l'assemblée nationale je crois que pour
faire des arguments qui ont du sens pour
avoir une réflexion approfondie
on le voit dans la nuit a dit des choses
et fois qu' il est habile dans l'art des
pirouettes sur un compliment était de
faire des pirouettes ou du backflip je
suis pas comme vous exprimer sur le
gouvernement lorsqu'il présente une loi
spéciale faut le dire c'est un peu un
déni de démocratie
il faut que les parlementaires aient eu
le temps de prendre connaissance de la
loi dans des bacs aujourd'hui on se pose
est-ce à la loi sur le retour du travail
au travail des juristes ils
suspendraient leur droit de grève on est
d'accord
qu'est ce qui explique dans l'histoire
en fait qu'il faut le faire sans arrêt
ça a plutôt commencé vers les années 60
une procédure d'exception dans le
règlement et l'osm gouvernement de
robert bourassa est là et ont un peu
abusé et donc eu des réformes on oppose
de 90 réformes au milieu des années 2000
et l'on est rendu avec cette procédure
là qui est un seul projet de loi par
jour qui peut être adoptée sous bâillon
on passe la nuit s'il 28 février
maintenant
je vais continuer le président